実
結婚してます
うんそうですこんにちははじめしゃちょー値下げ休みが終わりました
ちょっと知りたいです
でそうです普段ですねいう業関係の動画はチェガンとチャンネル発明した家を2箱に
あげてるんですけどもう今日はねちょっとねまぁ理由がありましてねチャンネル投げ
ますなぜかというとですね
この今日買ってきたこのデッキですデュエリストエントリーデッキ
js エントリーデッキってやつがまあ初心者でも始められるまあ誰でも始められ
るっていうデッキが
なねはい
なので今回のメインチャンネルでね指をしたことないなぁとかどういうハードなん
だろうとかな
やりたいけど怖くてできないという人のためのような動画を今撮ってるわけですこう
やってねカメラを向けて言ってるわけでも空ステイで今日買ったのはこちらです
さっきやったら前の技的でヨハネスで終わったんだよ
結構行かなきゃいけなくなるんだよ学校な姉結構遠いからさ
風が大変ですよいくのかまたねちょっとね人の動画が無意味かもしれませんけども
よろしくお願いしますわけで今回はこちらです3回目だ違う+説明の闇のデッキと被験
デッキの2つのデッキが今回入っておりますなんでですねもうこれは他社からで言えば
始められる
2つのデッキが入っ入ってるカードもすごいねー
なんか使いやすいカードばっかりなんだからもういい
4カードやったことが入ってそこの日々も思いますよ始める何から始めればいいんだ
って言うと思うとのねっとり撤去買えばすぐ始めるっていうね
代物なんですよだ
雑誌が出ていきましょうと
このねこれねでっきるかな団で僕好きなんですよ第まずはこちらですルールブックです
簡単女優ようなモンスターで攻撃して魔法とトラップを使って邪魔して戦うだけです
多分コモダチでねこれを1個パンて買ってを座喜味はやみねはいじゃあ私や光ね入って
高はね一緒に覚えていけばいいなって必ず
しよくわかんないよねっになって一枚こちらあそんなとこに10 p レイドが入って
ました水フィールドへ着いてまず床にカードを置けばいいかというかね1筆
ひとまず一目でわかるということでござい
います早速カード見てみましょうまずやめから見て来ます
go
なんでもないです dd に流派をペンドラゴンこれはね大強いで来ない方がいいん
ですよてんねカードがかっこいいと思ったらもう君を始めたほうが良くだとかっこよ
痴女所セーターブラックホールが入ってるベラフォースの入ってるよサイクロも入っ
てる
太陽カードばヅラじゃんこれ気持ちいいです風光の劇と闇の敵が入ってる
うわぁせほっドイツ製バージョンが別府ほっとあいずウォッチにできからを買うのって
えっ
うこれはすっ揚げ玉何か感じないかこの絵を見て溶けべきものはないかな
ここが君と決めたらすぐ始めようこれは凄いわコレは使えるってこっちが光のデッキ
です
僕私は少々で入ってるラッカーボールを入ってるか塾大キモっなるほどなるほど
なるほど
はいちょっとたっぷりなんですけどもデッキ等ネエ系500使いやすいカードが多い
ですまあやっている
んですけど払いらのカードはモンスター間このモンスターガードでまぁ戦うっていうの
です
とっても使いやすいです多分かなり分かりやすいもうガッツリ友情やってる人から見る
と
なんだよこのデッキはっていう人もいるかもしれませんが初めてやる人たら待ってる
ぐらいがちょうどいいと僕は思いますそう緑色色が魔法か別の魔法カードを使ってね
こうちょい安いやったね適合
学校行くとかそのするスってこっちが見えてラトリオとずやな
ま見てるとに落としなって書いてあるんですねと米良避けるのがトラップか
このツラカードを使ってねこう落とし穴取ってペッパーやはったりし霊的の統一して
いるそれで高は高い邪魔しちゃって
モンスターでこうねーなくに肺活量も gene 遊戯を始めようかなとかもっと渋味
苦味たらねこれとリティっ
って友達の子デッキを1個い負けてをただに強くなっていくのかいい年ですね
あっ
大事なお知らせを忘れてましたこれはね丁目5
実はですね今回ねこちらの10 d サイトリッジをねなんと100人分
準備してあります
もし良かったんですねこの動画のとメットなぁにリオカード欲しいミッキーほしいと
書いてくださいコメント欄の中から抽選で100人の方にですね
こちらの遊戯王カードエントリーデッキをねプレゼントさせていただきません
ます
うって